the Joe Rogan experience I thought it
was hilarious too that they wanted him
to not have so many wives they didn't
wanted to have the wives and they didn't
want a half hit that you know the braids
the long long braids I didn't didn't
like that didn't like the wives he
wanted things his own way he also played
politics brilliantly he mean he
understood from the early going that
that quote the chief of the Comanches
was going to be appointed by the
commander at Fort Sill you know it
wasn't just gonna happen and there were
all sorts of candidates jostling for
this and he made sure that it was him
that didn't make him any less the leader
of his tribe it didn't make him any less
of an independent person who the white
men had to deal with but he made sure he
had that one buttoned up and he was
challenged continuously I mean there was
there were continuous challenge to him
it's interesting historically that you
don't hear about him and the Comanches
when it played such a significant part
in taking over the West and settling the
West you hear about Crazy Horse you hear
about Sitting Bull you hear about the
the Sioux and the Apaches you don't hear
that much about the Comanches and you
don't hear much about Quanah Parker no
it was one of the great pleasures of
writing this book is that the these were
largely unknown things
I mean if you Quanah was one of them
another another discovery was you know
every we all know about certain people
running around San Antonio in the 1830s
je Davy Crockett would come to mind but
we don't know about Jack Hayes the
world's greatest you know the Ranger the
guy who sort of invented this anti
Comanche warfare invented the repeating
you know he first needed an invent but
he first used the repeating five-shot
pistol and then of course had a hand in
the invention of the six-shooter but you
everybody should know who Jack Hayes is
everybody should know I mean Kawana was
I mean Geronimo is Geronimo and he's
famous largely for one particular
particular breakout in the late 19th
century but you know Quanah was arguably
the greater man in in the reservation
period and I mean Geronimo in some ways
was kind of a was kind of a curmudgeon
yeah that was another part that I wanted
to get to was Jack Hayes and the
creation of the Texas were
so we think of the Texas Rangers today
we think of like Chuck Norris yeah you
know you really don't realize that they
were essentially a group that was
created to effectively combat the
Comanche exactly that's where they came
from
it's amazing the story when when you
talk about how it took like sort of
several iterations of these guys both
before they figured out how to do it
right and the the guys that came out
there essentially a lot like like a lot
of depictions of Navy SEALs like
renegades yeah like wild rugged rebels
and there they are there's the original
Texas Rangers is that Jack Hayes in
their military various there's Jack aces
well the lightest picture that's him
that's yes oh hey so the thing was of
okay San Antonio in the 1830s late 1830s
you have you have about 2,000 residents
it's the kind of thing out the final
outpost on the frontier and what what's
happening is Texas which now owns the
Texas which now owns Texas having won
its independence is giving out what they
call head rights so if you want to get
ahead right meaning free land so all you
had to do to get your free land outside
of San Antonio was go survey the land so
I had to do and you had it you know home
and so the surveyors would go out and
survey it and the Comanches would kill
them in ever more imaginative ways
because the Comanches understood exactly
that the instruments did steal the land
the instruments were the mechanism of
the theft of the land from them and so
part of the deal was to keep how can you
keep your surveyors alive and hayes was
originally a surveyor but he eventually
just got good at keeping other surveyors
alive and these guys who could do that
eventually became known as Rangers and
they evolved as Comanche fighters you
know fighting like Comanches did I mean
they learned bird signs to track people
they would you know make cold camps I
mean you never made a warm you never
made a campfire if you were around
Comanches I mean they would they would
they learned these these techniques and
techniques of Worf
there and they got really good at it
they've just had this one problem and
the problem was that they had three
shots yet Kentucky long rifle bang a and
two single-shot pistols and that's all
they had against Comanches who I would
encourage all of your listeners to go
and and look up this guy Lars Anderson
on the Internet yeah he's the he's the
Bo guy yeah okay so in him of what he
what he proved among other he went back
and he just researched it and a lot of
the things that I frankly found hard to
believe about Comanches once I saw the
Anderson videos you believe them yes
Anderson can I think it's ten arrows in
five seconds he there's no such thing as
a quiver you're holding it as a bunch in
your harm here I mean but all these
things that we you know we heard that
the Comanches could do underneath the
horse's neck and rapidity of fire and no
one's ever Comanches never stood in one
place and closed one eye as shot and
they never once did that they were
moving both eyes open anyway look at the
Anderson video it's really cool but what
that meant was that Jack Hayes and the
Rangers were in an enormous disadvantage
you know and then lo and behold he well
cut to the East Coast this inventor
named Samuel Colt had come up in the in
the early 1830s with a prototype of a it
was a it was a really ingenious little
pistol it was a five shot pistol made
and eventually made in Paterson New
Jersey and it is right there yeah is
that the Paterson colt there's a five
shot chamber that was popping up with
the same guy so yeah doesn't look like
open anyway it's a five shot it's a five
shot thing with with revolving cylinders
and as a great idea right absolutely
nobody wanted it I mean it was it was
like a sidearm for cavalry but the US
didn't have a cavalry so it didn't
really work out for some reason Mirabeau
Lamar the president of Texas ordered a
hundred and eighty of these things and
they can they found their way to Texas
the five-shot Patterson Colts and
somehow Jack Hayes and his guys found
out about them and they got a
of them they trained with him and they
immediately understood what it meant it
meant equalizing the warfare against the
Comanches it meant because now they had
they had a five shots or one
interchangeable cylinder now ten ten
shots in Eastern pistol now so in close
hand combat the world changed and and
not only did that world change but
eventually everybody was so stunned by
what by this development that the US
government ordered a lot of what ended
up being Walker called six shooters for
the Mexican war cult becomes one of the
richest men in America and basically
Jack Hazen Rangers redefined warfare
which is which is and people said this
about Jack Hayes and it's broadly
speaking true before Jack Hayes you know
people came into the West on foot
carrying a Kentucky long rifle and after
Jack Hayes they came mounted and
carrying a six-shooter yeah that was the
other thing that was really shocking was
that the US soldiers would try to get
off their horse to engage right right
because they didn't think you fought
mount the only people who fought mounted
were the Plains Indians I mean you know
nobody thought you've the fighting
mounted was not something anybody did if
you if you used a horse you used it in
the Dragoon Way which is you would ride
to where you were gonna fight get off
the horse and then fight but Comanches
were fully mounted and Rangers were
fully mounted and what they what they
used the Texas Rangers for in the
Mexican War which is they were there was
this terrible guerrilla problems and
these Rangers just went and cleared out
these whole areas and nobody had seen
this type of warfare before nobody had
seen this kind of ability to fight and
move and move mounted and move with
these well and nobody had ever seen
these what these Walker cult sees five
pound hand cannon six shooters that they
had nobody had seen those either and so
these crazy these these Rangers that
dressed any way they wanted to you know
sometimes with no shirts on and Serapis
and crazy hats I mean there was just the
Rangers there everybody was scared to
death of it
[Applause]